bienvenue dans la discothèque de radio
canada on lutte avec 2000 et michel
bonjour mais aussi sa famille ses rares
quand elle se rendre ici force
accompagnée d'un musicothécaire où le
joueur n importe qui na na na hey les
gars je n'étais jamais venu à sa famille
à son gré mais c'est formidable et à des
ars way et de modeler de polémia parce
que michel y en a ici du 33 tours du 45
tours du 78e et cb ouf widodo donc ce
qu'on ne savait pas sur dominique michel
la chanteuse sait que votre premier 45
tours est sorti ya exactement soixante
ans exactement civil uniquement car audi
ag bar clavier est du barclays et hoyé
ans vous vous êtes en france pour un
premier séjour vous êtes arrivé là on a
une carrière au québec est à construire
nous débuterons début labo comment ça se
fait
qui veut que cru en vous comme ça
puisque vous a produit deux 45 tours
j'étais un très ami avec raymond les
vagues
barclays aimait beaucoup raymond
lévesque et puis il avait appris la
chanson quand les hommes vivront d'amour
parce que c'était une magnifique chanson
monsieur batterie on l'avait toujours
monsieur barclays avait dit c'est un peu
comme on n'avait pas beaucoup d'argent 1
alors quand on l on ne mangeait pas tous
les jours alors le soir on sait par
rennes à part jean et des fois on allait
chanter dans un restaurant parce que là
des québécois est à nouveau là cette
époque là il y avait eu à glen et
revendique l'action est amusant alors
alors on allait manger puis le monsieur
ne disait si vous voulez vous chantez
deux petites chansons puis raymond
m'accompagne au piano parce que c'est
lui qui va chanter qui avait composé une
petite canadienne
quand elle sourit quand tout le monde
sourit aussi et lui chantait ses belles
chansons puis moi j'avais fait aussi je
pense l'autre côté on en calebasse cette
somme va aller
blanc voilà oui que marcel amont m'a
demandé de lui donner parce que je
chantais chez patachou à ce moment-là il
chantait là lui aussi
puis m'a dit ton rapide blanc je vais
faire ça ou ignorent ce conseil après
non plus sur dominique michel
super on ça c'est un objet rare le 78
tours
sorti en 1940 c'est oui qui joue de la
trompette cet enregistrement là qu'on
apprend ça on tombe un bon match et oui
c'est quincy jones et qu'il avait
enregistré à new york où elle oui on a
enregistré surprend à new york parce que
on n'avait pas ici les consoles où on
pouvait m'être séparée les instruments
et les cuivres ensemble et violon
ensemble et batterie et tout ça parce
que là bas ils avaient des pesticides on
avait une piste donc on chantait avec le
rck est alors violino quand même si
monsieur robert gates mais qu'elle dure
sans venir
et si john roos engine lab en direct oui
et puis la guitare que vous entendez au
début qui fait ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
si tony mottola
ouah je peux monarque est il y avait
tourné moto le quincy jones a fait le
super ce service avait pour une tare
images et avec eux c'est comment sait on
était tous à nos débuts à l'orgue avec
personne qui avait la grosse tête à ce
moment ctc dégoûte travaillait
est ce qu'on savait c'est dominique est
en forme c'est sorti en 1983 vraiment
dans la foulée des djeun founder of
being de claire pimparé si j'avais 50
ans est en super forme
ouais je savais pas quoi faire et puis
là il me dit mais pourquoi tu vas pas un
disque avec des exercices mais là on n'y
a jamais eu de vidéos n'ont pas dit non
alors je le disais prenez étiré moi que
je pense et ça je n'irai pas vous
expliquer vraiment très étiré votre
jambe droite à l'avant du rythme fallait
être attendre huawei à ce que vous ne
nous ménage y est pas normal il fallait
bouger mais moi j'ai appris à chanter
chez des religieuses de moi j'étais au
collège sainte-anne
j'étais dans la chorale dans les ados je
chantais c'est juste me surprend que
j'ai toujours j'en avais assez juste une
bonne oreille
ouais merci beaucoup de me dépêcher pour
ça qu'au passage dans la discothèque
comme ce bouquin l'eau ici on vous aime
ça c'est normal dans wii avec sa vie à
moi j'ai travaillé beaucoup travaillent
chez tes amis animés instamment grand
tamis
il me disait toujours bonjour ma petite
pitonner moi je devais répondre bah bon
mais on y va